let's start with the first question is
about doing YC the program the core
program that people know a common
question is why is YC worth the 7% what
do you think so when I think about YC
and I talked to founders about it
often times I tell founders it's in
their best interest to start building up
unfair advantages in their startup it
used to be that an unfair advantage was
capital mm-hmm but more and more now you
see capital being very widely available
and so I tell founders start thinking
about what other unfair advantages can
they get so with YC I think a lot of
founders always want to know about
fundraising
what's the unfair advantage you get
around fundraising first YC companies
get higher valuations typically 50% to
2x higher then companies who don't do I
see we see valuations on demo day
ranging anywhere from 4 million dollars
on the low end to 25 million dollar-plus
on the high end with most valuations
between 6 and 12 million put another way
when you raise money through YC you get
less dilution ii better investors we've
taken the time and energy over over a
decade to collect all of the best angels
and VCs and put them in one room the YC
batch is one of the most heavily scouted
group of startups in the world and so we
do the work for you to put the best
people in the room and then the final
one is that fundraising happens faster
when you go through YC some companies
can completely finish their fundraise in
under two weeks and almost everyone is
finished within two months as opposed to
other processes that you might run alone
which can drag out longer so first we
give you a bunch of unfair fundraising
advantages I say the next thing and I
would argue even more importantly is we
give you an unfair advantage around a
batch your batched with other companies
that are in the similar state as you are
and even if you're an experienced
founder and I've done YC twice
in the second time I was very
experienced founder I don't have at any
given time a whole bunch of friends and
colleagues who are all starting
companies right now and so being able to
literally be around a whole bunch of
other people who were just getting
started and who were grinding you know
within the first year - and so grinding
is extremely valuable from kind of a
friendly competition perspective but
it's always also extremely value of just
from a support perspective do all the
talk people who are there with you and
to have this whole variety of people so
you can find that people that you're
going to actually relate to the most the
next one is software what kind of
software does a typical investor give
you access to none with YC we give you
access to a whole variety of software
that gives you unfair advantages there's
a forum that allows you to ask questions
and hear questions from other founders
came from for you there's work at a
start-up which allows you to basically
recruit off of ycs brand
there's posting job posts on Hacker News
only YC companies can do there's an
investor database with over 5,000
entries including reviews and data from
every company that's ever done YC theirs
deals which are literally millions of
dollars worth of discounts given by top
companies there's a company a YC company
directory which allows you if you're a
b2b company to actually sell into other
YC companies it's one of the secret
advantages of being in Y see there's an
alumni directory which also allows you
to sell them to companies and also
allows you to find specific people to
give advice and finding there's a
knowledge base that gives you actual
clear tactical written advice on PR
fundraising growth etc and so most the
time when you're raising from angels
typically you get some phone calls
mm-hmm you get some email exchanges with
YC I would argue that you get a platform
and that's an unfair advantage the last
thing is additional programming a lot of
people think of YC is a three-month
program one-and-done
in fact YC is built to support you from
the beginning of your company to the end
of the company and two of the newest
programs that we've built are
specifically relevant to a lot of
founders one is a series a program where
we actually rebadge you with companies
that are now in the
anywhere between 150 to 300 400 thousand
dollars a month in revenue who are going
out and raising series a we teach you
how to raise a Series A we teach how to
deal with professional process we teach
you how to do a great deck and then we
send you out at the same time and
connect you with investors having an
advantage in terms of raising a series a
I would argue is one of the biggest
competitive advantages you can have last
we have what's called the YC growth
program and that's run by YC continuity
which is our growth stage fund and if
you're running a company from anywhere
between 50 to 150 employees suddenly as
a CEO your job changes it's not about
product market fit anymore it's about
how do you manage an organization how do
you build an organization and our growth
program essentially is a series of
dinners that teaches you all the tactics
around how to actually be a CEOs
managing organization as a YC founder
all of this is encompassed in the 7%
there's no additional equity that you
have to give to get in any of these
programs gonna need a software and when
your YC founder watch the founder for
life so it argue when you're thinking
about fundraising in this environment
where there's a lot of money stopped
thing what the money isn't unfair
advantage and start thinking about what
other unfair advantages the people who
are giving you money can give to your
company
I think YC looks great on that
perspective and it's pretty simple math
why it's worth it yeah and in tagging on
to that I wanted to cover I we don't
have it in the notes but your most
recent blog posts about generating
leverage in fundraising yeah I think
this is something that we oughta write
more about in Aaron's trying to do it
with a Series A program but can you
explain that problem and your proposed
solution for the average company I think
the base of the problem that a lot of
founders need to understand is that a
lot of fundraising advice is written by
VCS and the unfortunate problem when
you're reading a fundraising advice from
a Series A VC's perspective is that
they're not necessarily on your side and
so if you think about it the narrative
around fundraising is typically
something like you raise money when
you're running low on money when you're
at between 12 and 6 months of runway
when you raise money you need to be most
sensitive about valuation which i think
is completely not true when you raise
money I think almost strangely people
think about raising money when it's the
first moment that they think they can so
I see a lot of companies who are like
we're at we're an enterprise company
we're at a million dollars arr isn't it
time to go raise threes a that's where
all the VC say right I'd argue that's
like the earliest possible time to
consider raising a Series A and so this
whole kind of narrative around
fundraising especially series a fund
raising I think is designed to bring you
into the front door of the VC as soon as
possible
to allow them to get the best look
possible as early as possible right so
we should clarify that in financial
terms right so your valuation is
probably a little lower at that point
they can probably get a higher
percentage of your company at that point
and because you're scared that you won't
be able to raise you sell early and even
more so there are probably six or seven
terms around a funder around to
fundraise a series a fundraise how big
your option pool is how many board
members what the rights of the preferred
stock holders are and if you're going
into a fund raised without leverage you
have a hard time negotiating any of
those terms and so you might think
valuations the game but actually there's
six other terms that are really
important so I think that you know
Series A is what confuses a lot of
startups and I really want to focus in
on Series A I think some of these things
are different when it comes to raising
seed but Series A is really confusing to
a lot of startups and I think a lot of
the advice out there is tricky and a lot
of the common wisdom is actually tricky
the way that I like to tell this story
is I talked to a founder I say every
startup has a leveraged graph basically
it has a graph of how much leverage the
startup has over time and I'd argue that
that leverage graph in a good company
always goes up to the right but it has
peaks in it as valleys the best founders
I know
we'll raise money when their leverage
graph is at a local peak and the
founders that struggle will try to raise
money when they're in valleys and what's
interesting is that when you're at a
peak you might not feel like it's time
to raise money you probably don't need
money you might even be close to
break-even you got a lot of customers
you're building products great things
are going really really well and as a
CEO it's oftentimes hard to think oh let
me take my mind off of my company to go
raise money but in many ways that's the
absolute best time to raise money mm-hmm
that's the time you have the most
leverage that's time when you can walk
away that's the time when investors are
going to be more ready to chase you
versus you should chase them and so I
really tell founders hey think about
where they are on their leverage graph
and think about this way before you hit
that twelve months before you run out of
money yeah and how are you spotting
those points like I obviously I know
that we're in a better situation than we
were eighteen months ago who knows where
we're gonna be in eighteen months but
those local peaks and troughs how do you
as a founder identify those I think the
first peak tends to happen when you hit
product market fit okay I think what
happens when you hit product market fit
is that you have a lot of growth but you
are relatively understaffed and so your
growth to expenses ratio looks very good
I also think at that point if you're a
revenue generating business you have
more money coming in the door than
you've ever seen before
and so it's so funny because every
startup wants to get product market fit
I think most startups don't realize how
much a punch in the face product market
fit is but I think that's where the
first kind of peak is and I think that
what happens when you hit product market
fit is you start investing in scaling
your operation improving your product
oftentimes takes a second priority just
making sure your customers can consume
your product and that
counter-intuitively
I think that's the most strategic time
to raise a Series A I think that you
know your graphs are gonna look great
hopefully you've got revenue coming and
hopefully runway is gonna look good and
so
to me like that's that nails it hmm I
think when companies try to raise their
series a and when I say seriously I mean
you know five to ten million dollar
round from San whole Road VC I think a
lot of times in chat founders try to
raise series a pre product market fit
they have to be over reliant on their
story and second time founders
experience founders founders with exits
tend to do disproportionally well with
pre series a product market pre product
market fit series is but I think that if
you are not one of those founders if
you're a first time founder go in with
the numbers like it's it's just always
easy when you're going with the numbers
yeah and so a related question from the
internet Yousef asked how did you
validate your product market fit so if
this is in the context of social camp I
assume that's what they mean yeah I
think that like we've we've written
about this I think that you know the the
phrase product market fit was invented
by Marc Andreessen and then somehow
nobody bothered to look at his
definition and now it's just been
misappropriated in every way and like
the now common use of the phrase is like
I've built the thing that my customers
want but it's like even weirder than
that because like often times I'll ask
companies or companies ask me if I have
product market fit and I'm like how
would I know it seems like if you hit
product market fit
you'd be growing uncontrollably
everything in your company be breaking
you be doing all you can just to keep up
with the current customer demand like
that's the definition of product market
fit
yeah it's unambiguous whether that's
happening to you and like I think a lot
of founders think oh product market fit
is I've built the right product right
and it's like no product market fit is
what happens after you build the right
product and you distribute it well like
it's everything else it was a
culmination of some MVP kind of process
exactly yes no an MVP and product market
fit sometimes can be five years apart
and so yeah no I totally grew see like
you know an MVP the whole goals get any
customers coming in the door yeah and
then you kind of struggle struggle
struggle and some companies find a
product where now customers are just
beating the crap out of them to get in
right he says it put the market pulls it
out of your hands exactly yeah and so if
you're don't feel like growth is beating
the crap out of
you you are not in product market fit
like unambiguously did you guys hit it
at Socialcam I would say yes and no I
would say that we definitely got hit in
the face with growth however I would say
that we were particularly good at
distribution and not as good a product
and so I would say that our product
didn't retain as well as we wanted to
but we certainly got a ton of growth and
I think that you know in social you see
that happen and I'd argue that like you
know did we hit product market fit like
I would probably say no I probably say
that there's growth you can get that
doesn't reflect product market fit
because some part of pockemon product
mark if it is not only have all these
customers coming but they're doing what
you want them to do like your your your
your that your the goal of your product
is being served and the goal of
Socialcam was to get everyone to be
video creators when we were blowing up
we were blowing up on video consumption
but not a video creation
gadget so I think that's probably an
important part of people don't talk
about product that's like everything is
going well but it's like also your
business part is working right you're
not selling a dollar for 80 cents
exactly you're not you know you know
negative margins you're not like getting
users to do something that's like not
the thing you wanted them to do yeah
okay let's go into some questions
general like YC application related so
LC carrier asks how does YC feel about
companies who don't want to raise VC VC
money after the program and maybe a
canonical example is zapier who did a
seed round and then went on to be
profitable so i think what's interesting
about this is like of course we don't
care like these are your companies one
of the first things we say at the YC
kick-off in the beginning the batch is
that you're the boss you get to decide
what you wanna do with your company we
are not the boss and I think even more
so what's interesting is that we have a
large variety of company asleep a large
number of companies that never raised
from VCS are only raised from VCS way
after product market fit
profitable so and so forth no we love
those companies just the same I think
that um it's interesting like in many
ways I think that as YC has become more
mainstream we have to be louder about
what we like
were lumped in with VCS and we're not
VC's that's not the purpose of this
we're not here with the kind of sole
reason of how do we make sure we make as
much money as possible out of every
single company we invest in yeah that's
that's that's not the way YC works yeah
and to be clear if your company raises
money through YC and then goes on to be
wildly profitable profitable that's a
great outcome yeah provide no dilution
no pro rata no no like that's and it's
great for the founders like like this is
you know like I think we provide an on
board into VCS if you want it but like
by no means do you have to consume it
right yeah I mean I think this is kind
of related to did you read Aaron's post
this week about advice because we've
entered in this position that's in
between like VC traditional VC and
universities we're just thought of us
like the advice-giver
and like you have to have permission to
do this thing and we don't want certain
people it's not really the case now
related another super common question
Emile s'en Rodriguez asked do companies
need to be incorporated already to
participate in YC so this is another
thing that I think is extremely
important to understand a lot of people
talk about the growth of YC + YC
certainly has grown pretty significantly
batch sizes are a little bit more than
doubles since I lasted YC in 2012 I
would say it's responsible growth we've
prepared ourselves and I think we still
give a really good at high quality of
service but what it's also done is this
allowed us to have such a variety of
companies at a variety of stages so YC
has always been about the super early
stage and will always be about the super
early stage we can help you incorporate
and we help a lot of in companies
company could incorporate when they come
in there are a lot of companies that
literally start writing code when they
join YC there are a lot of companies
that are pre launched when they join YC
I think why cease expansion has allowed
us to also work with companies who are
post-launch
and might have incorporated or raised
small amounts of money but I think
sometimes
people want to interpret that as like a
change of strategy as opposed just an
expansion you know this is not an
either/or it's not an or it's an end so
and and also I think it's really
motivational to be in a batch where you
have some companies that are pre-launch
and it's still trying to kind of get
that MVP out the door and you have other
companies that are like starting to take
off mm-hm and I think that you know when
you want that motivation you come to a
dinner you see it come be taking off and
you think to yourself we got to get back
to work I think that motivation is is
kee-yai that like cohort pressure you
see people follow-on after YC to just
having dinners with their friends yeah
every couple weeks yeah
you had another question about YC types
of companies so Alex Rodriguez asked
what do you look for in startups that
haven't had good growth but continue to
push through for example Airbnb that
makes you accept them into the batch I
think what's interesting is like this
concept of traction mm-hmm I think is
very interesting I think that there are
complicated complicated or not
well-defined thoughts that people
simplify so if I tell a start-up oh I'm
looking for attraction I think what they
think of is that I'm looking for growth
and like they think that oh if I have
growth why would I need YC right it's
kind of this kind of catch-22 when I
think about traction I think about a
little differently I kind of think how
much time have you been working and what
have you done and am i impressed with
the amount of stuff you've done in the
amount of time you've been working and
so to me like Airbnb what they had done
in that year before they apply to I see
and by the way I think this story is
like told in such a strange way it was a
year it wasn't like ten years
everybody was struggling before they got
into YC it was a year but what they had
done was impressive they had launched
multiple times they had been the housing
host for the DNC convention and the RNC
convention they'd been on CNN a bunch of
times then like they'd done a lot of
impressive things the product wasn't
working but you couldn't look at the
last calendar year and say oh these guys
aren't out there grinding it
and so to me like that's far more
important than when they've been whether
they've been successful I think the
second thing is that the Airbnb guys
felt like they were onto something like
a lot of a lot of investors talk about
like what's your secret sauce what's
unique insight what's the thing that you
know that other people don't write and
it's such an overused phrase but it's
it's kind of true the Airbnb guys really
thought that people would stay in
strangers houses and they thought that
it could be a significant better
experience than hotel and they believed
that through and through yeah and even
if you don't agree when you see three
people who actually believe that you
think to yourself well why not try right
well why not run the experiment because
you you were the one that went to bat
for them you have to get into YC so what
was it about them or about the project
had you used a product before you told
PG about it before I told PG I had not
used the product no K I'd been on the
bottle yeah I'm not used to no because
back when I when I was working with them
they were really focused on events and
so not renting out whole house is either
not rental houses renting out rooms and
still doing the air bed thing yeah and I
didn't go to the RNC or DNC convention
what I saw in them was exactly what I
said about traction yeah they just kept
on working like one of the things that
we say to YC founders some of the PG
always used to say which is that
companies to do well in YC you have
office hours with them they tell you
they made your problem you brainstorm
some potential solutions and the next
time you talk to them they've moved on
to some other problem and with the
Airbnb guys it was exactly like that and
the other thing is that they were happy
and gracious you know like it's easy to
help people who are like nice they're
nice they're hard-working yeah committed
and I think that this part of the valley
like doesn't get talked about a lot like
if you're nice concise you know and
hard-working like more often than not
people will try to help you like they
won't go out of their way they won't you
know like stop their business to help
you
business but like will they give you an
hour like yeah yeah I think that like
sometimes you have to warm up right
sometimes you have to you know show that
you're being serious but yeah like this
is not a situation where people feel
that your success somehow it takes away
from them or somehow reduces the size of
the pie so yeah and I think people are
always looking to meet motivated like
it's not this weird like close friend
Network situation where it's like I
don't know I'm done with motivated
inspiring people that's what I think is
so weird about the valley is that like
on the East Coast all of the networks in
my experience tended to be around like
what you've done in the past like where
you worked where you went to school what
club you are in right and like here it's
the like strangers email me every day
yeah I reply to them every day like this
is like the way of the valley like
stranger like literal stranger and so
like the only thing we all have in
common is we're all crazy enough to try
to do startups and I feel like inside
every founder there's this feeling like
if you're stupid enough to do a start-up
we should have each other's back because
I'm stupid enough to do it too and there
aren't a lot of people as stupid as us
yeah and you have enough good will to
keep replying yeah because in those
emails you get a lot of crazy ones yeah
and I would just say that knowing what
to ask from the right people in a clear
concise simple way you can get through
to most of them is it a crazy cold
emailing is a skill that everyone should
work so related to that the Airbnb guys
working on different types of things in
the first year I think it's worth
explaining that like that doesn't
necessarily mean pivoting five thousand
times so yeah that's a good point
I really I've been trying to kind of
nail down what's the difference between
pivoting and iterating because iterating
is clearly good and I think pivoting is
oftentimes strictly inferior so one of
the things I think about is that when
you're iterating usually there's lots of
things that you can learn about from the
previous version of your product because
oftentimes you are keeping the same
customer or very related customer and
you're solving the same problem or very
related problem mm-hmm
and so for me like I get smarter every
time I enter eight I feel like iterating
is kind of letting the running the
scientific process and I'm learning
every step of the way
to me pivoting is when you basically
take things outside of your realm of the
previous thing you worked on mhm so in
effect you're changing the customer
drastically are you changing the problem
drastically and usually even though you
can kind of justify it to yourself often
because there's similar technology like
you don't have to completely rewrite
your code I would argue that like you
are not learning very much from what you
just did you're just working on
something else and I think that rapid
iterating is amazing I think rapid
pivoting is is really bad and I think
that you know Sam and I can I give two
different pieces of advice on this that
I think reaches the same point you know
someone asked Sam when do you should you
pivot and he said when you've exhausted
every idea every single idea on your
current problem that you're solving yeah
and I love that construction but I feel
like founders lie to themselves like I
lied to myself as founder all the time
and so I like to tell people like time I
like to say like give some in a year or
two like it's it really can take that
long like it often does yeah
long and like it was like concerted hard
work yeah just like I do it on nights
and weekends sort of of constant
iteration um I do think that like there
are these there's this myth that if you
build it they will come and that's just
like a myth like behind every one of
those stories is a lot more hard work
mm-hmm
I think another pivoting problem is that
people pivot and apply the same solution
to multiple problems and like the
solution is just never that good and so
you just get locked into this thing that
won't work yeah another thing somewhat
related to that Airbnb guys it's just
how compelling they are phaidor Paretsky
asked about basically pitching your
company so they say what are your
thoughts on the strategy of just like
being very very aggressive in like
enthusiastic about pitching your company
in terms of pitching to investors and
are there other techniques you encourage
to make your pitches sound more
compelling or exciting what I didn't
understand as a founder was that anytime
I pitched an investor it was the you
know basically round to over a thousand
pitch that they ever gotten mhm so think
about it this way any gimmick or trick
that you think might be unique has in
fact already been tried by one of those
thousand people before you and so I
think that often times people kind of
resort to weird public speaking gimmicks
or oh I gotta make a memory or gotta
like create an impact or like a sales
type things and it's like honestly it's
a lot harder to sell to like a
salesperson and a VC is kind of a
salesperson it's kind of like it's a lot
harder to do an email marketing campaign
to a founder that does email marketing
like I'm a little bit immune to drip
campaigns right it's like and you're
smart that's awesome that you're smart
but by the way there are a thousand
other people you're smarter than you so
when I think about doing the pitch these
are the things that actually stand out
to me the first thing is is clarity and
conciseness I think that um more words
are actually bad when you actually study
really good salespeople on the phone it
turns out the customer talks way more
than the salesperson and so when you're
in a really good investor meeting the
investor is fully engaging and is
basically like giving ideas and
brainstorming it doesn't feel like a
pitch anymore right when you feel like
you are pitching for a long period of
time that's a that's a bad sign
typically especially an early
fundraising later fundraising is
different but see it even series-a so
one clarity and being concise I really
think most are apps can be explained in
three sentences the two don't start with
your background like you're telling a
story and
often times the mote and often times
people default to telling a story
chronologically and argue that like
actually like you should be thinking a
little bit more like pulp fiction laughs
like tell the interesting parts of the
story first get me hooked oh yeah and
your background if your background isn't
one of the top three most interesting
things happen I'm gonna start up and it
probably you shouldn't start with it now
for some startups it is right like for
some startups the person's background is
but rare together I think the other
thing that's important is that the
investors to clearly understand the
problem you're trying to solve clearly
understand it I think so often founders
when it gets straight to the solution
and so what's weird is in that in that
first couple sentences like what I want
to get out of it is I want to know what
you do right I don't have to be sold on
it I just have to I just want to know
what it is right
you know me knowing that Google is a
search engine where you go to a website
you type in something you want to know
you click the search button and then a
bunch of web pages that are relevant to
what you typed popped in great yeah I
don't have to be convinced that I want
that I just have to be convinced that I
know what that is right then I want to
know anything about traction anything
like have you launched by is it growing
you know anything like that I want to
know that you have tacked on your
founding team and I want to know why
what's the problem that you're trying to
solve and and why you wanted to try to
solve it mm-hmm for me those are the
things that like if you can get out in
the first 30 seconds mm-hmm I can engage
in a conversation with you mm-hmm
and I think the other thing that I tell
founders is that like if you do a bad
job it's your fault like unfortunately
like if the person you're talking to
doesn't get it mm-hmm after the first 60
seconds it's not because they're an
idiot like it's because you didn't
explain to them well and like that's
really hard to hear but like I just tell
founders that straight and I'm like look
I've been pitched like to infinite times
so like I think I'm not dumb
well I mean like it doesn't really
matter if you're smart that's true maybe
unfortunately you're asking me for
something if you got a dumb it down for
me either way so yeah and I think that
oftentimes what's weird is you have to
throw away other instincts yeah forced
you always have to throw away your
customer pitch the investor is almost
never a customer and so it works when
the customer is almost the exact
opposite of what I work on the investor
second you got a throwaway jargon mm-hmm
right what makes you sound smart amongst
your peers makes you understandable by
someone who's not one of your industry
peers and so I think there are all these
like things that like people try to use
to make them seem impressive yeah which
are like driving people to do the exact
wrong thing when they're pitching to a
VC yes like I actually think you need
somewhere between like sixth and ninth
grade language like that's it oh that's
a fundamental for me on your blog all of
this does like why are you complicating
no no no and I think that's what's weird
is that like you're speaking right and
so like if you're not clear and concise
the more brainpower after you use to
figure out what you're saying
yeah like the more the less viable
conversations gonna be mm-hmm and I
think like related to this people can
conflate salesmanship with confidence
and so many of these founders are very
confident yeah
but oftentimes they you know it's like
that Steve Martin quote like they're so
good they can't be ignored that reason
like they don't really have to like take
the money from a certain investor so
they can just confidently walk into any
room yeah communicate it clearly well
you know what I think creates I've only
seen two things reliably create real
confidence not fake confidence one is
you've done something impressive in the
past that makes confident the second is
you have the numbers yeah all right like
you got one of those two things like you
deserve to be confident so you know for
first-time doubt is the numbers huh and
I would underscore this for
international founders I think it's
really really hard to clearly
communicate what living in another
country in that specific problem in
another country is like to an investor
here that's so important that's so
important but what's fun is that when
you get it right what's fun is like I
mean we've invested a bunch of companies
out of Nigeria
you know when they explained to you that
you can have five credit card processing
machines at the hotel from five
different companies and you can swipe
your credit card in each one of them and
it won't work
yeah see I have to pay your hotel bill
in cash you're like oh if that happened
I'd be super painful but you know right
as opposed to saying oh credit card
processing doesn't work in Nigeria right
yeah it's like I'm kind of worried I'm
like come on you know right like when
you can when you can tell a story and
paint that picture and like it took me
how long it took me 10 seconds to paint
that picture and I get told up but you
get it right as opposed to let me tell
you about the history of credit cards in
Nigeria right yeah I mean and by the way
Niger is 200 plus million people another
thing that like I don't know how I see
actually that's a really important thing
to facts are really important one of the
things I think is interesting about a
lot of investors is that they know like
2 inches on a lot of different subjects
and like if you know like 6 inches
they will think you're very smart and if
you know 1 inch they'll think you're
very stupid yeah and so like just doing
some friggin research and like when you
talk like oh i often tell founders like
write down everything you just said and
count the number of facts and like if
you didn't say any facts just say some
facts oh it's great so do you this is
related so David Chen asks how do you
find mentors and advisors but when
you're pitching your company are you
pitching it to mentors and advisers to
get warmed up are you just pitching it
to random people at Starbucks I think
that like one piece of advice that
Justin Khan gives that I really like is
[Music]
aggressively practice pitching friends
colleagues existing investors before you
go out yeah and that like there's
something that you can learn from every
run of it and I think that one of the
strange and unfortunate things is that
fundraising is so hard and the process
in general has been made so painful that
founder send the shy away from it and
they want to do it as fast as possible
with as least practice as possible and
unfortunately I think that that doesn't
serve them well and so I think practice
is really really
onto this thing about mentors so I get
asked five times a day can I be a mentor
to a company that I I would consider I
have never met them a formula I don't
like the mentor word I feel like it's an
old-fashioned word it kind of it reminds
me of the day of like master and
apprentice mm-hmm where like you
actually needed someone like you're not
a blacksmith like someone has to teach
you that [ __ ] or else you not be able to
do like you could drive but you can't go
on the internet and Google search box
just like you know it's like and and I
feel as though for some reason and and
and by the way I think in corporate
America mentors are probably extremely
helpful I don't know I'm not really been
punching more Cabrera but I think a lot
of this advice comes out of corporate
America and comes out of like career
prep centers and all that stuff I think
for me personally I give advice to a lot
of startups and I'm happy to like this
part of my job and I wouldn't do this
job if I didn't like it to me when
someone asked me to be a mentor it's
asking way more of a commitment right
it's like what I'm saying is that
without being your mentor if you ask me
a question in a clear and concise way I
will
99% of the time reply within a week
with what I think is the best answer you
get that for free for free and so what I
think about is again someone asking me
to be a mentor I'm like oh god well what
else do they want well it's like hey hey
Michael we've never met do you want to
be in a single relationship together
yes a little right and Anna and I also I
always feel like when those people if
they just emailed me a question of yeah
like what question do you wanna ask him
it let's just pretend I am your mentor
right let's pretend I'm everyone's
mentor you already have that like what
and you know if you're looking to like
put my name on something that like
that's silly who cares right like no
investors gonna be like oh well because
Michael signed up as your mentor I'm
going to invest like no no good investor
will say that I think what a lot of
founders have found both in YC now is
that if they asked me for help I'll try
to help them yeah and like
that's what you want so stop asking for
a mentor like it's funny because I
actually had this conversation with
someone else and I was like you know
this company that I helped a bunch I was
like I don't think they like I'm not
their mentor and then it was funny
because one of the guys was like oh I
talked to them and they say you're one
of your they just they just asked for
help and I and I was happy to help them
so don't raise the stakes of a new
relationship just just ask for when you
don't and you don't have to and they
also don't know like maybe you just give
them terrible advice maybe you say yes
to being their mentor and then you drive
them off a cliff yeah I mean like advice
is one of those things right like take
it with the grain of salt yeah I don't
think there was nobody who I felt
fulfilled a traditional mentor role in
my time at what at a in the valley like
it that kind of like took me under their
wing and showed me what was what
right like nobody did that right a lot
of people helped a lot of people and I
asked help but nobody I almost feel like
a mentor in some ways is taking
responsibility for your success yeah and
like nobody does that especially if they
haven't invested in you but even if they
have they don't do that
usually it's just like after enough
years your friends yeah and then then
maybe that's it like after enough years
you like meet up just because yeah which
is great yeah all right let's go to
another question so I just want to
clarify this one on the first page
building eat neat asks what if anything
are you looking for in a start-up that
wants to be part of startup school
anyone can do startups anyone can do
startup school okay I think we designed
it like to be extremely explosive we
designed it to be step one yeah like in
any state you're in you can get value
out of this thing and that's what we
decided yeah and that there will be
these grants given out but that's gonna
be decided after the fact yeah or I
guess at the end Ryan Karl Mercer a
frequent podcast and the question asker
asks what's your preferred way of
organizing your time I hate giving
advice on this because I don't think I
do it particularly well I
I have like an Mei star important emails
and I use a to-do list you know that's I
think like probably the biggest time
hack I've had has been since I've had a
kid I think the biggest time that I've
had is that I've been one lucky enough
that my parents close so they can help
watch my baby and then I think the
second thing is I've been fortunate
enough to be able to afford someone to
help at night I think those are probably
the two things that are keeping me like
functional right now but I do not think
I am a model of organization let's go to
the next one so John Rigler asked can
intrapreneurship be effective and by
that he means starting something within
a company I believe I recently returned
to IBM I have a patent and yet only a
vague ideas about how to signal and
organize other like-minded folks within
the company could this path sabotage my
dreams so in a caveat this answer by
saying that I've only worked in a big
company for I think 14 months of my
entire working life and I have exactly
one experience with intrapreneurship and
it did not work out very well so you
know in my single experience it didn't
work I can't give you advice on how to
make it work for you or if it does work
I mean certainly there are big companies
that invent new things all the time so
somebody has figured out how to get that
done but this is an area I have I would
argue almost less than zero knowledge of
okay Horacio Chavez asked how would you
approach an investor who says I won't
invest in you unless you have a patent I
probably would just talk to another
investor yeah that's not a typical
response especially in in in technology
startups I can't speak to biotech and so
and so forth but in technology startups
that is such an untypical response it's
almost indicative that that investor is
not very good yeah or they're trying to
say no
I'm sure I mean but like that's if
that's a bad way of Solio nicely like
greater ways to say no yeah yeah all
right so yeah LM Ronnie asks why in a
sense it's just we're gonna have
relationship questions now why does it
feel like entrepreneurs aren't marriage
material SH and entrepreneur look for an
entrepreneurial spouse marriage that's
interesting question so I started dating
my wife when I was doing a company I
thought I was marriage material I don't
know I think um I think what they're
trying to get at is that so like say
yeah so you're really dedicated to
social kamon is taking up a lot of your
time and all these justin.tv oh really
yeah and that consumes all your time
therefore you might not in someone's
eyes be a great partner and I think
that's what they're getting at but I
mean I I think different people like
different things I think that um you
know some relationships are really
motivated by work and people find
someone who is really into their job is
something that's attractive yeah I think
some relationship some people are in LA
way yeah you know but I don't think I
think that it is pretty easy to see how
intense an entrepreneur is working on
their job pretty early in a relationship
and you know if that's not something
that someone likes then they should move
on to something that they like yeah yeah
in that second question an
entrepreneurial spouse I would just say
a spouse that's okay doing their own
thing whatever that might be just
they're okay doing their own hobby or
whatever I hate to be like general on
this but my wife certainly was that way
my way is certainly somewhat who didn't
need me to be around 24/7 yeah exactly
and I think that's good all right yeah
ha asked another question how intense do
you really have to be to found a
start-up I think that this is such an
interesting question because like
intense is such an interesting idea
right so like okay I'll tell you like
two different versions right yeah so
justin.tv
there were probably at the max point
five or six of us living in a
two-bedroom
apartment one two people were shared
bunk beds one person had a room to their
own one person was sleeping in the
living room and I was thinking on the
balcony we worked the office was the
apartment yes we worked you know when
we're at home and our roommates were the
people in the company so there you know
that was you know that was that part and
then moreover the building was full of
other startups yeah and so my friends
were started founders and we're going
through YC and you know so on so forth
right on one hand that sounds like
really intense right I don't know though
like college is kind of similar right
you're living with people you're going
to school with like oftentimes you know
they have similar interests like you're
kind of enclosed in this space you're
all kind of doing something similar like
yeah I don't see it as that different
now what I will say is that like so so I
think when describing the steady-state I
didn't think of it as like this like
massive intensive like thing what I will
say is that the lows are low yeah
like when people talking about emotional
roller coaster I like I hate that phrase
cuz so cliched but like there have been
times in my startups history where I've
like gone home and cried like there have
been times where I've thought pack it up
last five years of your life down the
drain there have been times when I've
thought you know I've lost my best
friend there have been times where I've
thought like all kinds of stuff right
just bad bad stuff so I think that like
you need to be resilient you need to be
able to that kind of stuff I'm not
saying that you like shove it away being
able to get past those lows yeah you
need to be able to wake up the next
morning or a couple days later and get
back into the game so I would almost
argue that the resilience thing is maybe
more important than the intensity thing
I kind of feel like it doesn't feel like
intensity when you're doing the thing
you like to do and your setup should be
the thing you like to do hopefully yeah
yeah I think I think
intensity can be used as a synonym for
like [ __ ] guy and that that's
definitely I would just wanted to spell
that like that is absolutely not true
that we likes [ __ ] know it just
don't be an [ __ ]
no I don't but but like I going back to
the Airbnb thing I think intensity could
also be a signal of working efficiently
and many of the really great founders do
that like not sure I don't like the word
intensity because I feel like it's like
morally ambiguous like I would say like
passionate yeah like you know passionate
yes [ __ ] no yeah like I feel like
intensity could be passionate or it
could be asked like I just have this
horrible image of like hey I'm like the
intense hustler like I just get [ __ ]
done
people don't like salespeople as well
it's weird to like talk about this world
but it's like like when I when I was at
justin.tv were just starting rows three
engineers in Mia right like it's
sometimes I think people find hard to
understand how much of an engineering
backbone there is to this whole thing
and a lot of the like norms are kind of
I would almost argue invented by
engineers or former engineers and so
like you know people not wanting long
meetings people not people wanting
concise communication like a lot of
these are kind of traits you find in the
engineering community yeah and like
salespeople and engineers are like water
and oil like so or else is a
stereotypical salesperson that yeah the
kind of cartoonish con television ish
sales person and engineer and so like I
had to learn a lot like I had to learn a
lot about just the engineering culture
and I feel like I've embraced it as my
own now but like it's different it's
it's it's not business it's not New York
like it's not business guy first here
it's kind of engineer first yeah it's
definitely not polish no don't wear a
suit so just a couple more questions
about startup school do you think
there's a particular stage of company
that this would be most beneficial for
or doesn't matter you know it's funny I
always get this question in the context
of applying do I see yeah and I always
tell founders it's like sometimes people
phrase applying to startup school
applying to I see as if we were charging
$50,000 and it was a 10-year life
commitment it's free yeah I think it's
free to apply to I see it's free to
apply and it's free to do startup school
like if you're curious about it
founders they don't tend to talk
themselves out of things right try it
yeah try to apply YC like if you get an
interview you learn more like like try
start of school if you like it great if
you don't like don't like like talking
yourself out of free things is like kind
of weird right like you yeah okay Kevin
Haley used to say that he would scream
at people we're giving away free lottery
tickets what are you doing it's so true
it's so true so it's it's just like you
know don't don't talk yourself out of
stuff like yeah part of being a founder
is just kind of like some amount of just
do you know at some amount of just do
and if you find yourself talking
yourself out of things like maybe we can
talk yourself out of the thing you
should be doing right now
yeah and so yeah there's no contract
there's no like we're not gonna come
hunt you down if you want to apply later
to I see it won't count against you
there's really no cost yeah like in any
in financial moral occasional all of the
potential cost is no cost yeah okay so
then assume we get over the fear of
applying of doing startup school how do
you get the most out of it I think that
the way you get the most out of it is
you devote a significant amount of time
to making progress in your company goals
every week do not think of this as an
educational program yeah don't think of
this as a program where you sit there
and you're gonna learn about how to be a
founder like learn by doing this is a
learn by doing type business and so you
should think where do I want to be from
a metrics perspective from a milestones
perspective at the end of startup school
and map out that path through startup
school and like where do you want to be
week over week to get to where you want
to go I think that's how I get the most
value but if you can
move two times faster to get your MVP
you two get to launch your first
customers cuz you're in start-up school
you've got a great service for free and
it's way more it's way better than you
know whatever lectures we could do yeah
all right man thank you all right thanks
much
you